this is your body wash which i have to
say like i was a oh
oh dear let's serve up some news sunny
side up
apparently there's a new syndrome it's
not fomo
it's foda which is in style reports that
fotus stands for
fear of dating again whoa and a lot of
singles are starting to get real sweaty
palms about resuming in-person dates and
experts want people to realize that
you're not alone everyone out there is a
little rusty as well
including your new date michelle
thoughts i think you have to be as
honest as possible you know we have been
home and quarantined for a really long
time and i think like get it all out
there don't even waste time getting to
know each other politely over text
you know you went through so much
trouble just to meet for that coffee in
public right now
it's all gonna mean something you know
what side of science are you
on you know do you have health insurance
what do you plan to did you finish your
script you know what i mean do you have
to like sell your car to make that music
album
i i can't we're not talking about me i'm
married but the point is
yeah i say get it all out there you know
just don't wait
pop sugar report that beauty products
are going
waterless what okay so check this out i
know because i said the same thing
brands are taking out the water and
giving you dry goods
instead shampoo bars dry moisturizers
and body wash powder so this is this is
okay i i was like your shampoo and this
is your body wash which i have to say
like i was a oh no dear
yeah i was a big borax girl like
remember we used to put your hands in
the thing and do that does everybody
remember that
and i missed that i love scrubbing with
the granules so i'm feeling
this um um at first i was like h
to omg i don't know how i feel about
this like what are you talking about but
it's actually good if you're traveling
imagine you're camping or something
i don't know maybe it's a stretch i just
kind of like soap is that too much to
ask for
you know what though for traveling
because you can't
travel it's open so every time you make
a point you're like
i'm like when you travel it's great
because you can't bring water
dion warwick the legends
we know that you are our sister in
bridgerton hood right
uh and uh a topic near and dear dear to
your heart
is reggae john page uh gq says the
dashing duke
should be the next james bond
uh i'd watch that someone needs to take
over for daniel craig
he's retiring from bond after his fourth
and final uh double 07 film no time to
die
and um reggae is in the mix do you think
he'd make a good one
honey as far as i can say you can do
anything you want
i totally agree now there are other
names in the mix let's see there's a
michael b
jordan who would be great too right
harry styles is in the mix
what do you think of harry styles
understood first up we all love to
pamper our animals
clearly but travel and leisure reports
that you can now check
in your dog your little fur muffin
into the first ever luxury hotel for
dogs it's called
urban mutton london's west end and it's
like
soho house for your dogs darling it
costs 200
to join and then you can sign your fancy
fur ball up for fitness classes
spa treatments or an overnight stay in
an indoor sleep hut with mood lighting
and room service
doggy acupuncture massage and reiki
they're all
on the spa menu ross would you check
those chihuahuas in
uh yeah i'm actually really impressed
with you just side note
i would bring my dogs there i have to
say you know i um
they're not like spoiled necessarily at
least that's what i thought to myself
but then i was
i was thinking about massage for dogs
and then i remembered
i one time had a massage therapist come
over to massage one of my dogs
i love people who go all out and the
actress taraji p henson is certainly one
of those people she told in style that
during lockdown she built herself a full
beauty salon at home
complete with a real cash register
that's the part
by the way that was the detail i love
too she says it's her own little world
and it makes her feel good and it's
stocked with
her tph by taraji hair care line
and she hosts her instagram series from
the salon
sharing tips on how to nourish and
protect your hair
and scalp thoughts i think it's really
fun that she put a salon in her house
the cashier the register makes me laugh
i hope she takes her own personal check
but then i thought what would i put in
my house like if i was you
to really take a swing like that what
would you do thought about it
it would be a movie theater with a soda
fountain machine
you know what i mean i love fountain
soda
i want you guys to check out everything
michelle
buteau so to watch yes welcome to
butopia
yes on netflix critics choice award
winner and i tied with jerry seinfeld
it's just a slice of heaven also
netflix is the circle huge huge
phenomenon
oh my god it's so good it's bad you're
just gonna want to watch watch
watch all of them okay circle emoji send
and to read michelle's book
survival of the thickest yes do that
plus-size essays in a small-minded world
you better get it
the world cannot get enough of you so we
did three in the doggy bag with your
stuff today that's the first time ever
but there was just too much good stuff
to celebrate
[Music]
you